at the time because I feel like you see
it out you saw it at that time - um I
looked at him like okay I guess I can
live with that I mean tell you why no
because what I thought no I'll tell you
why why did you do that because when I
was I when I was 22 I worked at a coffee
shop called the pannikin and I liked a
band called Drive Like Jehu all right
say there are math rock band I love them
what's math rock math rock is just punk
rock but it's like repetitive right and
just kind of I don't know yeah yeah so
anyway um Rick Fahr was the lead singer
and he was he came in he had one shoe
missing always know he just walked in
the concert hits to missing oh that's so
cool yeah yeah and you know he had money
he was from Del Mar oh yeah
right so this guy's money but he has he
purposely no shoe right and then he
would he was by himself
and he had one of those hobo gloves yeah
it's summer he doesn't need to wear
fingers yeah yeah yeah yeah and you look
at his fingers and they were dirty
uh-huh and then he had a cappuccino like
a heel he'll like this that guy you're
[ __ ] he's the best okay
he's very talented so he's holding it
like they're super turned right and then
right he would would do twitches oh my
god and drink and they kind of talk to
himself right and I would be I was you
know you're fascinated by him oh yeah
I'm doing the coffee but I'm looking at
I mean because I've all you know have
all his albums and uhm I memorized he
wanted to be his understudy yeah and in
fact here's another thing that they do
right
drybeck Jehu right you know when they're
on stage see my legs they would he would
play the guitar but he would cross his
legs like this so I you know I would go
home and pretend I'm in a band I would
cross but I love that because it's like
your fandom is what drove you to do that
yeah here's the thing is is that you
know I if I get more if I get bigger
than I am I think I'm going to like
become
or weird it's contrived it doesn't
matter I would have like dirt on my face
for no reason you know a man it's it's
forced you're not that weird yeah but
people think he wants to give the
perception and I do say that matter like
what everybody here likes you
oh wait how weird it cool to a man I
mean but you are cool you're a
Birkenstocks guy and just admit just
admit it
yeah what you love Birkenstock I like
that one pair of cuz that's camo on it
okay my point is is that um me I mean
but here's the thing though it's when
people when I'm be myself
people still go he's eccentric
yeah like when I was you what I don't
have an eccentric guy yeah for sure
like even at the show somebody said you
had some of the executives said that you
were eccentric like a why because you
know we know how the table reads go like
everyone's there's no camera show yeah
okay so the president of like the studio
yeah yeah right they're all they're
everyone's they're the cast everybody
and what I do is do we at this room and
I waited for everyone to sit down and
that was the last guy to sit down and I
would be there the first I'll be the
first guy there you know I was just wait
Pete I would just wait in the back and
wait for be able to sit down and then I
would sit when we started and people
thought that that was being artsy and
weird I think that you're for sure
neurotic but I don't know if you need to
add the twitches you know what I mean
just for its like that no don't do that
with the fingers yeah we start showing
up like that the table reads are gonna
be like anyway we can write this guy
Luna know when I was on MADtv it went
because I don't know if you guys see
where's the glue took a little road oh I
know what you do you would you would
pour it dry it and peel your hands yeah
but I would do it at table rates and
wait for the network what would they say
I had three bottles of Elmer's glue and
it would just drip him on my hands and
do this and just let it dry and do my
read like that yeah and they were just
like this guy's great yeah but you loved
it
you should kind of feels like I know it
feels like a compliment right yeah
there's nothing in our heads it's like
like my wife's always like you to me
she'll be like what I laugh at [ __ ]
she's like you have mental problems I
think you're a psycho and I go yeah I
think I enjoy and yeah when she says it
and yeah sometimes other people say it
they're like you really [ __ ] up and
I'm like yeah
[Music]